Дати визначення музею — складно.
Ми тут книжки колекціонуємо.
Там опудала тварин стоять.
У світі дискусійне питання:
«Що таке музей?».
Музейники завжди намагаються
зробити свій музей цікавим.
В Україні безліч чудових музеїв.
І їх потрібно відвідувати.
Але для того щоб в музеї було цікаво,
має бути діалог музею із відвідувачем.
Цей музей має таку унікальну колекцію.
І сам він розташований в унікальному місці.
Ми в Луцькій надбогемній вежі.
Це був один з головних в'їздів
до міста Острога.
Ця споруда побудована за європейським типом,
який називають барбакан.
Споруда, яка має дві брами і більша частина якої
розташована за межами міських стін.
Первісно вежа була одноповерхова.
А далі вона розбудовувалась.
Складається із овальної півкруглої частини,
яка виходила за межі фортечного муру.
Та прямокутної частини, яка вписувалась в фортечний мур,
який примикав з обох сторін до вежі.
Тач-панель. Тут можемо побачити ті головні брами,
які збереглися до нашого часу.
Чи інші важливі споруди збережені до нашого часу.
І браму, в якій ми перебуваємо.
Луцька брама розміщена так, що тут і видно,
що вона розміщена за межами міських стін.
Теж барбакан — Татарська вежа.
Названа так, не тому що татари на неї нападали.
А тому що хитрий князь
Костянтин Іванович там поселив татар.
І татарська громада існувала в місті
до середини ХХ століття.
Вони просто асимілювались.
На південь компактно розташовувалась єврейська громада.
І їхнім центром є синагога. Будівля
Великої Острозької синагоги збереглась до нашого часу.
Вона має оборонний характер.
До середини ХХ століття єврейська
громада мала близько 20 синагог у місті.
І друкарня, й [Острозька] академія
не виникли на пустому місці.
Острог середини XVI століття
лежав на жвавих торгових шляхах і входив
до п'ятірки найбільших міст України.
Порівнювали його з Волинськими Афінами.
Придворний поет князя Костянтина [Острозького] — Симон Пекалід
у своїй латиномовній поемі «De bello
Ostrogiano» — «Про Острозьку війну» пише:
«Місто прекрасне і тут, Острогом його руси назвали.
Славу ж античних часів — принесли йому вільні науки».
З 1916 року, та й ще раніше,
в місті формувалася книжкова колекція.
Почалося все з громадської ініціативи,
які назвали себе «Братство ім. Князів Острозьких».
Вони формували книжкову колекцію,
яка стала основою цього музею.
У 1986 році тут відкрили
«Музей книги та друкарства»
Цей музей розповідає важливу
історію початків друкарства в Україні.
Й історію меценатства в Україні.
Тобто князь Острозький, із своєї кишені,
дав гроші на те, щоб друкувати книги.
Це Іван Федоров, це 1581 рік,
це «Острозька Біблія».
Це книга, яка стала першою повною
друкованою слов'янською Біблією.
І практично до сьогодні православні видання біблії друкуються
за редакцією Острозької Біблії.
Це абсолютний шедевр і з поліграфічного боку.
Книга прикрашена ось такими заставками, кінцівками.
Потрібно сказати, що, мабуть, чи не вперше в історії друкарства,
використано одночасно шість видів шрифтів.
З них два — грецьких, чотири — слов'янських.
Дуже важливо було, що не тільки
зрозумілою слов'янською мовою[видано].
А тоді велася дуже активна полеміка,
що божественною мовою є тільки латина.
Ну ще грецька хіба.
А слов'янська не є мовою Божою.
І не може бути така книга,
як Біблія, нею видрукувана.
Важливо було й те, що шрифт був зрозумілий.
А важливо тому, що народ наш
був грамотний на той час.
Це дуже важлива книга для міста.
І після князів Острозьких місто почало занепадати.
І дослідження історії цього міста  почалося з Біблії.
Тобто дослідники взяли Біблію, і такі:
«Чому не в Києві? Чому не в Москві?  Чому в Острозі?».
І ця вся колотнеча привела до того, що створився музей.
Відновилися навчальні заклади.
Відновилась Острозька академія.
І та спадщина — ми її маємо зараз.
Вона трішки тяжіє над містом.
І ми дійсно шукаємо себе в тому минулому.
Найцікавіший і найуспішніший період міста.
Якщо ми так прагнемо до успіху — то це
непоганий варіант, щоб усе було гаразд.
Де ж це таке видано — щоб
з першого разу попасти.
Записуйте в журнал.
[жартує] Книжку вкрали, винесли, нема.
Наша колекція — це книги.
І це точно не той предмет, який ми дамо відвідувачам у руки.
Інколи жартую, чому не збереглося в Україні
жодного «Букваря» Івана Федорова?
Бо п'ять школярів взяло його в руки,
а шостому не було що в руки брати.
Те саме і з нашими експонатами.
Діджитал рішення, оцифрувати експонати.
Представити книги в цифровому варіанті.
Це те рішення, яке на поверхні.
Тобто ми це просто взяли і зробили.
Це ще не проста книжка, до речі.
Це анонімне середньо-шрифтне Євангеліє.
Один з давніх експонатів нашого музею.
Книгу знайшли в церкві села Ляхівці.
І ця книга за наказом
Петра Конашевича-Сагайдачного передана сюди.
Це оцифрування і ця техніка в нас
у партнерській програмі
з бібліотекою рукописів абатства і
коледжу Святого Джона.
Вони ще в 1960-х роках, коли була
велика загроза Третьої світової війни,
в розпал Холодної війни, зрозуміли, що є
речі, які не зможуть цю війну пережити.
І для себе обрали рукописи, бо вони розуміють,
що це унікальні речі, які ніхто не копіював.
Тоді, у 1960-х, вони взялися за мікрофільми.
Фотографували і зберігали це у плівках.
А в кінці 1990-х перейшли на цифрові носії.
Працюють вони і в Україні.
Працюють, власне, здебільшого
з рукописними колекціями.
І я дуже радий, що ми
в нашому музеї це почали.
Сподіваюсь, що теж купимо таку техніку і
будемо оцифровувати інші книги, які нам цікаві.
Або за запитом дослідників.
Дуже вдячний, що хлопці з Міннесоти
дали нам схему, як це робити.
Це дуже легко, просто і якісно.
Потім ми бачимо, що це якісний результат,
який дозволяє повторити, щось
надрукувати чи представити в мережі.
Відвідувачам це цікаво.
Особливо, наприклад, «Енеїда».
«Енеїда» Котляревського, перше видання.
Важлива книга в історії України,
яка сприяла поширенню української мови.
Але власне перше видання було
видано без дозволу Котляревського.
Видано в Санкт-Петербурзі.
Той, хто наважився на видання,
підписався Максим Парпура.
Уявіть собі: Котляревський бачить,
що в магазині продається його книжка.
Напевно, він був в шокові.
Написав для Парпури:
«Хлопчик Максимко, ти не так робиш!».
Якось помститись законними способами він не міг.
То помстився текстом.
Дописав частину, де Еней спускається
в пекло, і там дописав, що:
«Якусь особу Мацапуру, — Максима Парпуру,
— Там шкварили на шашлику,
Гарячу мідь лили за шкуру
І розпинали на бику.
Натуру мав він дуже бридку,
Кривив душею для прибитку,
Чужеє оддавав в печать...»
І так Котляревський увіковічнив
вчинок Максима Парпури.
Але Парпура теж увійшов в історію України.
Цей чоловік зробив перший
україно-російський словник.
У кінці цього видання він
помістив словник слів:
Ялівець — моживельник.
Шкварчить — говорять про сало,
коли його топлять в жир.
Загалом, те, що було незрозуміло там,
північних широтах, він намагався пояснити.
Більшість тих музейників або науковців,
які працюють з книгами,
не використовують білі рукавчики.
Упередження до того, що ці рукавчики потрібні,
мають масову культуру і культуру аукціонів.
Що для підтвердження того, що річ цінна,
використовували рукавчики.
У рукавичках затуплюються відчуття.
Ми можемо механічно пошкодити книгу.
Тому, щоб мінімізувати наш вплив на книгу,
краще використати просто чисті руки.
Я дуже не люблю термін провінційності
застосовувати до музеїв,
тому що це фіксує почуття меншовартості.
Є різні музеї, є різні колекції.
Ми все життя вчимося.
Інша річ, як у кого це виходить.
І як є бажання у кого переймати досвід.
Набагато простіше і легше
вести звичне життя.
Займатись або не займатись науковою роботою.
Але музей однозначно має рухатись вперед,
оскільки дуже стрімко розвиваються
новітні технології у наш час без яких
ми просто вже не можемо існувати.
То музей не може залишитись осторонь,
архаїчно показуючи книгу у вітрині.
Але музеї не мають грошей.
Так виникає ситуація, коли є велике
бажання, є багато ідей і практично
немає засобів їх реалізації.
Але коли дуже хотіти, то все виходить!
[звук з аудіогіда] У першій залі,
що розташована на третьому поверсі...
Перший аудіогід, по-суті, вартував нам
мінімальні кошти.
Для диктора купили пляшку коньяку.
І пляшку вина для його дружини,
бо вона дуже хвилювалась.
Коли звільнили цю залу, то зробили мапінг і
на всі стіни проєктуємо історію вежі.
Робили тривимірні копії, 3D-моделювання.
Створювали графічні копії для того,
щоб могли відчути незрячі.
Дехто запитував, а чому ми це маємо робити,
якщо в нас немає таких відвідувачів.
А я навпаки кажу: у нас немає цих відвідувачів,
бо ми нічого й не зробили.
І ми зробили аудіогід з тифлокоментарем.
Він дуже описовий.
Він надає людині розуміння, де вона
перебуває, який простір навколо неї.
Так само зробили путівник для нечуючих.
Наша місія така — зробити це максимально доступним,
щоб людина почувалася гідною.
Я завжди запрошую всіх
дружити із своїми музеями.
Для того щоб знати своє коріння,
треба водити дітей до музею.
Останнім часом спостерігається
така відрадна тенденція, як сімейний туризм.
Коли кілька родин сідають до автомобілів,
беруть дітей і привозять їх до музеїв.
Це класно! Це круто!
Так і має бути!